today I want to talk to you about taking
JavaScript to the edge so the vast
amount is that we have in modern IOT is
is is crazy compared to what we might
have hired five ten years ago you know
if I choices of devices hardware
attachments you've got languages to play
mechanism different different deployment
mechanisms and frameworks and I'm gonna
try and demonstrate all of the different
options that you do have and how we can
then use these to deploy JavaScript to
edge devices so choices firstly you need
to cite which device are you going to
run your cord on now in the past you may
have only had the option of a for a few
small system on chips or a couple of
microcontrollers you might've had a very
restrictive set of development and
debugging tools you know maybe the only
we're on Windows or OSX or Linux
architecture you might not be in able to
control that just whatever you had at
the time fortunately this isn't the case
anymore so here is a subset of single
board computers that resin currently
supports you can use any of these in any
project that you'd like we've got the
raspberry pi and the raspberry pi zero
these have got different architectures
different clock speeds different price
points and basically you pick what works
best for you you know you've got the
raspberry PI's they've got USB they've
got HDMI everything you'd expect we've
got the Intel Newark these are x86
they've got all of the i/o that you
would expect on a normal computer opiate
less we have the NVIDIA tx1 and they've
also got the tx2 these are designed for
doing machine learning at the edge
you've got the Raspberry Pi costing
about thirty pounds the PI 0 or costing
around ten pounds the txt you costing
around three hundred four hundred pounds
so again it depends what you're after
and what you're looking for but the
point being you've got a choice for what
works best for you so
this gives you a blank canvas on which
to build and maybe if you chose the
Raspberry Pi you have your device is
designed to have some swappable hardware
or hats or additional hardware so we've
got hats for the Raspberry Pi which
stands for hardware touched on top love
the name by the way on the Left we've
got the sense hat this was designed for
the Astro Pi project which aimed at
getting contributors code in out of
space and this actually this this hat
was sent to the International Space
Station with some code by members of the
public we've got a speaker hat this
means that if you want your device to be
able to make noise play music that kind
of thing that's easy you put it straight
on the GPIO GPIO header we've got a
motor controller that means any DC motor
you can supply some power and then use
the Raspberry Pi to control those motors
we've even got a high def touchscreen
that you can put onto something in the
size the palm of your hand so these are
examples of different kind of inputs and
outputs that you can very easily add to
your eye or tape project with the
minimal of installation and setup and
often there's libraries already
available everything's ready to go
so you've chose your device you've
chosen the additional hardware that you
want to add on all of your sensors all
of your output mechanisms are kind of
thing now how are you going to deploy
that code to your device so with modern
IOT deployment there wasn't really that
much option that many options so being
from resin I'm going to talk about how
we have enabled IOT projects to deploy
their code to their devices containers
containers a grace
so containers are a way of packaging up
all of your code and your dependencies
and putting them into an environment
which when you run them will be exactly
the same you can make sure that your
target can download can run
can clean up after your cord without
knowing a single thing about your
application itself these containers are
created from images which our assembly
is building on top of one another to
define the environment in which your
cord should run so I'm going to talk a
little bit about how we make those
images and then how we get those onto
devices so images settle is just like
this rock balancing thankfully it's a
bit easier than that so you start out
with what's known as a from line so
sorry this is a docker file and a docker
file you used to define the image that
you want to build they have a set of
commands each one being aligned and each
command in the docker file will produce
a new image which is the image before it
plus whatever additions that command has
added so generally the first command
that you add is a from line what this
says is use an existing image as a base
on which to work from and this is known
as a base image as you might imagine so
what we're saying here is take the image
reson /r as baha'i 3-node and build upon
it now this image was created by resin
to run on the Raspberry Pi it's it's a
debian environment it has nord
pre-installed npm pre-installed and it's
the bare minimum that you need to deploy
a javascript application next we've got
a run command so this run command what
it says is take my base image run
apt-get updates or run the debian
package manager and decide what packages
are available and then we're going to
install curl and Elsa let's say that
these are dependencies of your
application you know maybe you're going
to do some downloading of music and then
playing it so what we've done here is
we've taken the base image we've added
another layer which says I've got the
Debian based image with curl and ulcer
on top and that's it
so what we need to do next is copy our
application or our application source
code into our image so we've used the
work command what that is is it says
every command that I run from this point
on should be in the working directory
and in this case I've chosen us our
source app you can think of this as
equivalent to doing CD USR source up in
your shell and then running some
commands it's running in that directory
after that I've taken a copy command and
this copy command says in the current
directory there is a directory called
source in that directory there's my
source files I want to take those source
files and add them to the working
directory of this image so each line is
creating a new image the the workday
line would create an image that's got
the Debian Nord image it's got curl and
Elsa it's got some me today let's say
that the working directory of this image
is us our source up and then there's
another image that is built on top of
that which says all of my source code is
in that working directory so now we need
to find which code is going to be run
when when we when we turn this image
into a container for this we use the CMD
command CMD command says when we take
this image and convert it into a
container what should happen when we
start that container what what should be
done
so this says I've got an image when this
image is turned into a container and
it's run it should take the update J's
file that we added in the previous copy
step and it should run it with node so
simple as that
okay so we've got an image how would we
then deploy it to our device I'm going
to kind of rush through this a little
bit because I'm not talking about resin
I'm talking about JavaScript so you
would create a a precaution on the resin
dashboard and download the resin OS
image for your device resin OS is an
operating system that we've
created specifically for devices which
have a thin host OS they run exactly
what you need nothing more and your user
container will go on top of that and
that's all you need
that's worse resin or s it will connect
to our dashboard and handle all of that
so this is this would be how you do that
but that's irrelevant you would install
the resin CLI again if you want more
information on this we can look at the
documentation but in general you just
install a resin CLI you do a resin login
which would take your application your
user account and associated with your
local instance of resin CLI now here
comes the magic so we would use resin
push so you'd do resin push and then
whatever your application name is this
would tick your current directory which
includes your docker file it includes
your source code it would package it up
and it would send it away to our cloud
build servers our cloud build servers
come in different architectures you've
got x86 we've got a our 64 we've got arm
v7 anything anything that you can deploy
to we've got a native cloud builder
ready there to build your cord into an
image so you've sent your cord to our
builders it's built successfully
hopefully and this then gets sent to
what's called a registry the registry is
a a server in the cloud that holds a lot
of images and you ask for an image by
name it checks if you have access and
you download it so we've got that and
it's been installed well why why would
we want containers what why your contain
is a good thing for IOT deployment now
first for the first glance it might seem
you know we've done a lot of all this
work but what has it given us why why is
this something that we want to do so
let's talk about the benefits of
container based deployment in an IOT
saying isolation
so the first isolation
so when you're writing code for an hour
to device often it can be a lot more
complex than your typical desktop
application you know often you need to
have a lot closer to the host operating
system you know a lot close to the
hardware on the device on which you're
running you might need interface with
the networking or again specific
hardware
isolation allows you to draw a line
around your user application and so this
is allowed to do this specific set of
circuits if something goes wrong in
those tasks we get rid of that container
and we start again what that means is
your host operating system cannot be
affected where with a container that's
acting badly
unless you've configured seriously Bran
what this means in the IOT saying is you
don't brick devices so if you imagine
you've deployed an IOT device to
something in the middle of the sea you
know the middle of our Artic ocean if
that device suddenly goes offline there
is nothing you can do other than send
somebody to go and either fix it or
recover it and that's not an easy task
if we use containers and something goes
wrong we tear down that container and we
start again and the device is fine its
pristine reproducibility so when you're
using containers you have an environment
in which your cord roams in that
environment is the same on your device
it's the same on your local dev
environment it's the same on your
testing infrastructure it's the same
everywhere so if you discover a bug in
your code you can reproduce that bug
locally and fix it locally and in the
setting of IOT security is a massive
thing these devices are in people's
homes they're running machines they're
everywhere security is a big thing if
you see a security problem you need to
fix that security problem then and there
and being able to reproduce and fix
locally is is brilliant application
delivery I think personally is the most
important part of using containers for
IOT so for a typical IOT for a typical
desktop application you've got several
different
methods of deploying it you've got
auto-update is you've got web apps
you've got at a push you've got FTP if
you need to but if you have an IOT
project and that device is not on the
same local network that you are your
options are pretty limited we need some
way of telling the device that the
update is ready we need some way of the
device downloading the application
without knowing anything about the
application itself and we need a method
of tearing down that application should
something go wrong now docker containers
enable you to get all of these things
for free this is what docker was
designed for and this is what docker
does very very well also if you have a
container and you push an update you've
got a device out in the field that's got
a 2g connection we're talking you know
two-three kilobytes a second what you
can do is say okay I have this container
and I need to move to this container we
can work out what the difference between
these containers is we call it a Delta
just download that Delta on the device
and apply it to the container that the
device has this means we move from
container to container bay with the
absolute bare minimum of data
transferred so we've chosen our device
we've chosen our additional hardware
we've chosen our deployment mechanism
now we need to choose our software stack
and we're at a JavaScript me up so let's
assume that we all want to use
javascript because we all know a little
bit hopefully so why would we want to
use javascript at the edge that's an
interesting question
there are a lot of programmers that know
JavaScript using the stack overflow
developer survey from 2018 70 percent of
respondents use javascript seventeen
percent use typescript is a superset of
JavaScript and whilst it is typically in
being a language - you use to create web
applications in recent years it's
definitely proved itself to be an
extremely competent unuseful
general-purpose library allowing
JavaScript to be run at the edge means
that we can take all
all of this knowledge in which 70% of
programmers are already familiar with
and apply it to a complete whole new set
of problems we have a gigantic existing
ecosystem of packages for JavaScript I
took this graph from module cons calm
today we've got you know a lot of
popular package managers at the bottom
I'm then far and away at the top we've
got NPM with what is it five hundred
thousand packages at the start of
September and now in July at 450 plus
packages a day it's it's got a lot the
beauty of this is that these can be used
in an IOT saying with zero changes in
general normally so the next point
doesn't just apply to JavaScript but
applies to higher level and more modern
languages in general so in the past for
embedded devices it would have initially
it would have been originally written in
C or C++ or at a push even assembly but
you know partially this would be this
was because we'd need to squeeze every
single CPU cycle or every single bite
out of memory now we've got single board
computers which run at gigahertz
they've got gigs of RAM this just isn't
that much of a problem anymore and
programmers will prefer to use prefer to
use languages that aid maintainability
and ease of use ease of debugging rather
than getting that raw performance and I
think that's why JavaScript has been
used on the edge so much already and why
I think it will continue to do so so
what does javascript at the edge
actually look like
surely it's got to be different
hopefully not it should be exactly the
same because it's JavaScript it runs on
the node engine it has the same data
models it has the same behavior so you
can write code for the node engine on
your desktop and it should behave
exactly the same
- cord that you run on your device
ignoring any hardware differences you
know maybe you're simulating some
hardware your test week should be just
as effective when you run it locally -
when you've run it on your device and
your Nord module should be installable
both locally and both on your device and
they will exact any behave in exactly
the same way so I want to show you what
how well JavaScript can lend itself to
edge programming so this snippet of code
is from an order library created by a
resin to interface with the sensor that
I was talking about earlier it takes a
handle the LED matrix chooses an XY sets
pixel pretty standard JavaScript before
seeing this it's pretty standard this
it's not special in any way you wouldn't
be surprised if you see this on some web
application it doesn't change at all
it's what about using the sensors
because the sensor has a lot of sensors
what surely it's gonna be a bit hard to
use them nope we've got exactly the same
JavaScript that you'd find in any other
web application it's pretty standard you
query you create a handle for the IMU
also known as the inertial measurement
unit request the sensor date and we'll
provide a callback again standard
JavaScript you'd see this anywhere
this is typically doing something
extremely non-typical for javascript and
it just works it does exactly what it's
supposed to do we've got the same
JavaScript objects that pass to json dot
stringify we've got the same error
handling as a normal Nord chord by
callback wood it just works even
hardware events are made extremely easy
so I'm sure everyone's familiar with a
JavaScript event emitter but so what
what you would do in this case you would
ask for a handle to the joystick you
would set up callbacks for joystick
events so in this case we've got press
release and hold and this is again very
very typical JavaScript and this is
running on a device out on the edge so
we've chosen our device we've chosen our
additional Hardware deployment mechanism
we've chosen our software stack the only
thing left to do for you guys to write
some code so one of the beautiful things
about containers
you often make a distinction between
application state and application data
anything that needs to be kept should go
in application dere and how we actually
do that a reson is what's known as
docker volumes and these are just
segmented parts of the file system which
can hold their application state on the
other hand would be lost so you would
design your program in a way that if it
needs to recover and go back to a
certain point you would read application
data now this is nice because it means
that if you have a bug in your code that
would change your application state in a
weird way if you tear it down and bring
it back again and it works going from
data to state then it should work fine
this is a JavaScript at the edge and I
hope it was very
[Applause]